If my Dutch test results showing my estrogen and progesterone were both depleted,
should not have any, is that okay?
Yes, as long as you're okay with any symptom patterns that might results from that.
So let's say your cancer is in full revision.
And let's say you had breast cancer that was ER positive or too positive.
And your in full revision and your estrogen and progesterone are like zero on a Dutch test.
If you're having symptoms because of that, which you can have all sorts of symptoms having two role of progesterone and estrogen,
you're not going to get into that right now.
Could you add a little progesterone or estrogen back to the mix?
You just kind of be really careful. You have to, it's just like, you know, that's that's much more of a faster driver than adding a food back.
So I'd be careful with that.
That's a decision you want to make.
If you know if you did not have an estrogen or progesterone or her true positive cancer and your in full revision and your depleted progesterone and estrogen, you could maybe add a little estrogen or progesterone cream.
For you, I would never add estrogen, but you could add some progesterone cream. That's something that you're going to have to talk to your folks from doctor.
You would put me on a roll of clear for estrogen, because dim had to be up by a suit of roll of clear works like dim, roll of clear has dim in it.
Instead of clear dim, clear dim has other things that can, that can do other things that could possibly have amped you up.
The roll of clear is just pleeter beaded. It's just has less things in it.
So that's why I recommend that.